[BEEPING SOUNDS]
SPEAKER: Google Cloud Pub/Sub
is a messaging service
for exchanging event
data between applications
and services.
Cloud Pub/Sub is
great for distributing
event notifications.
Take an example of a service
that accepts user sign-ups.
It can send notifications
whenever a new user registers,
and downstream
services can subscribe
to receive notifications
of the event.
It also allows you to respond
to events as they happen.
Cloud Pub/Sub forms part of
Google Cloud's Stream Analytics
Solution, which provides a
number of useful applications,
such as performing
sentiment analysis,
identifying general
patterns and trends in data,
monitoring the performance
and reach of campaigns,
and crafting responses
in real time.
The Cloud Pub/Sub lab is
available for use with the G
Cloud command line, as well as
through Google Cloud Platform
Console.
You can check out the link
to start Quick Labs here,
and for a limited time, you
can try these labs yourself
for free.
Each of the labs
cover the activities
of setting up a topic to hold
data, subscribing to a topic
to access the data, and then
publishing and consuming
messages with a poll subscriber.
Next up on our quest
is Cloud Spanner--
Qwik Start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]